la première télé thani c'est pas ça
c'est incroyable je crois que ceci ne
change quoi c'est à dire si ce dernier
joue single can't remember des témoins à
gaza
[Musique]
ça y est enfin
camille l'étape à tapas chante et a
déboulé 500 inscrits c'est pas facile
non plus qu'est-ce que vous avez des
neuf mais ouais à ses wagons chanteur
qui nous juste qui nous endorment je
peux pas chanter devant un public que je
fais tout le temps juste devant des gens
ok donc je suppose que vous n'écoutez
pas vous avez raison ce sera pas pour
cette fois ci camille hockey prochaine
fois je n'ai pas roulé comme ça c'était
un grand coup droit
pourquoi parce que j'ai attendu depuis
ce matin 9h et que je suis la dernière à
passer par exemple j'étais agressive en
plus avec eux normal à 38,5 degrés on
apprend vite
non maintenant rajouter je vais arrêter
de parler là
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à l'aise il a le droit de
s'exprimer vraiment regardé bouton tiers
des grâces que j'ai une pierre du puy de
dôme masters c'était un bouton siècle
c'est un bouton de cette histoire donc
là je pense 20 21 ans c'est pas ma
première nouvelle star c'est ma deuxième
j'en ai fait une à 17 ans la première
fois il est 21 heures tu arrives à 9
heures du matin j'ai vomi toutes les
demi heures parce que j'avais 39 5 me
dis venez pas enrhumé tout machin est
envoyé comme il nous fit sud en général
à la base j'ai croisé andré manoukian et
auch est sûre entre les deux vaut mieux
un peu sur la tête un peu les espoirs et
du coup en fait il n'ya que ça te faire
dire des choses et y est tu as vu quand
je chante dans les montages il faut
toujours que sur la vie de maintenant
que devant moi faisait pas ça je voulais
unique j'ai arrêté de parler avec moi je
suis partie en cacahuète j'ai dit j'ai
dire enlever mois le micro et j'étais
tellement je suis jeune j'ai besoin de
faire ce métier et c'était tellement
méchant ce que pourrait nous refaire la
chanson et c'est ça que je voulais
[Applaudissements]
hugo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la butte à l'eau on les entend pas les
marseillais avaient sciemment
saignant ouvert avec ses chaussures
genève à chanteloup
[Rires]
avec les mêmes aventures c'est consentir
faux
st
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
+ 0